[Music]
well now the Chicago mayor Lori
Lightfoot has lost re-election she'll be
leaving office soon a lot of journalists
in the city are thrilled about that
because Lightfoot waged a war on press
Freedom at one point she even refused to
let white reporters interview her life
had also pulled the press credentials of
reporter William J Kelly because she
didn't like his reporting on Wednesday
at a city council meeting Kelly gave
Lightfoot this send-off the people of
Chicago elected you
you shut down our schools you shut down
the churches you shut down the
businesses you did the one thing that I
thought could never happen as somebody
who was born and raised on the south
side of Chicago I never thought in my
life that I would ever see the city of
Chicago brought down so low as you have
managed to bring it down
shame on you
that is
a legacy that you are going to have to
carry future historians are going to
have a hard time understanding how you
are even how you ever even became mayor
of the city of Chicago I hope that you
realize what damage you have done to the
city I hope that after today's city
council meeting you will pack your
suitcase
and get the hell out of my city
it's gonna be getting the hell out of
office that's for sure William J Kelly
is a journalist in Chicago and he joins
us now uh William great to have you on
the program I can't help but notice that
was a city council meeting it wasn't a
press briefing it wasn't a q a that
looked like a public comment why was
that the circumstances of your statement
to Mayor Lori Lightfoot
absolutely thank you so much for having
me well well yeah like everything else
in the city of Chicago now it's you know
Mission Impossible uh meets Kobe Ashi
Maru we had uh traditionally mayor
lifefoot would do a press conference
after every city council meeting but of
course this being her last city council
meeting due to the fact that she lost
her re-election campaign she canceled
her city council press conference so I
knew that if I was going to have a
chance to speak to her at all I would
have to register for the public comments
section and uh and that's exactly what I
did it was a lottery only five people
only five names were drawn from a big
glass bowl and miraculously mine was one
of them right and I was given three
minutes and you know 60 seconds worth
the distance run times three you know
Luck of the Irish there but not without
effort you had to enter the lottery to
get a chance to speak to your mayor why
was this so important for you to say
what you said to Lightfoot well it's
extremely important well because over
the course of the last few years a
number of people have contacted me
reached out to me and said you know
here's a question I would like for you
to ask the mayor uh here's something I
would like you to say uh police officers
who have been overworked and obviously
mistreated and a spike in police
suicides as a result and uh and I feel
like this particular city council
meeting was an opera was the last chance
that I may ever have to actually tell
mayor Lori Lightfoot not just what was
on my mind but what was on the minds of
so many Chicagoans and I'm just thankful
that I had the opportunity to do it and
I heard in that moment where you told
her you hope the history is written
accurately that you intend to write that
book that you intend to write the
history of these years in Chicago we
could hear that in the video clip of
your appearance there in the city
council what we cannot hear William is
the response of the mayor or the council
what did they say to you at the end of
your statement well you know to add
insult to injury after I'm done giving
my public comment or Victim Impact
statement as well how I actually viewed
it uh one of Mayor lightfoot's city
council allies uh uh heckled me you know
she actually said uh you know she called
me a derogatory name and then she said
that all of the problems that mayor Lori
Lightfoot uh you know had to handle or
mishandle was the result of the pandemic
and you know I just I guess channeled
the entire city of Chicago and let this
city council woman know that she was in
fact the pandemic
well in Chicago for the moment at least
it looks like there's some relief from
the pandemic we hope that the
circumstances in that city which have
been largely made it unlivable for the
past several years are alleviated and uh
we appreciate you hopping on with us
tonight William J Kelly and for that
moment in front of Lori Lightfoot
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight